[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: So today, I am very excited
to have Dr. David Bates with me.
Dr. Bates is the chief of
general medicine at Brigham
and Women's Hospital, where he's
also the chief quality officer.
He has been the sort
of pioneer in studying
patient safety, health information
technology, and how they intersect.
DAVID BATES: Quality
is important in health,
because it's really at the
root of everything that we do.
My first passion is safety.
And safety is the first part of quality.
I got interested in safety when the
results of the Harvard Medical Practice
Study came out.
And they showed that lots of patients
were being harmed unnecessarily.
I was interested in
physician decision-making.
And it became clear
to me that if we could
computerize drug ordering,
that we could make
a really big dent in medication safety.
And medications were the
single leading cause of harm.
The reason that I care
about safety is I think
it's awful to harm people
with the care that we deliver.
And I know that we can
do better around this.